- So in some sad YouTube news
that probably qualifies
for its own Darwin award,
a man was killed while
attempting to do a YouTube prank.
Two individuals in Tennessee
attempted to prank-rob an individual.
They were carrying butcher knives
and the would-be victim,
who was not in on the joke,
open fired and killed one of the two men.
It's important to note
that we don't have all the facts here,
but it's entirely possible
that these circumstances
might give rise to self-defense.
And self-defense probably makes sense
under these circumstances.
In Tennessee, you don't
have a duty to retreat
if you are not engaged in illegal activity
in a place where you have a right to be
and you are reasonably worried
of an imminent threat of
deadly or serious harm,
and you think it's reasonable
to use deadly force to fight that.
And here, two people
brandishing butcher knives,
threatening to rob you,
probably meets that definition.
So let that be a lesson.
Don't do stupid things
for internet fame or clout
and subscribe, or I'll see you in court.